[Applaudissements]
pour prouver ton amour je prends un
glaçon et tu viens de le prendre dans la
bouche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fête
je suis dégoûté ont des routes sont les
missions des routes
j'ai toujours là on demande à venir
[Applaudissements]
alex persique de prendre
je veux montrer que chaque chaîne de
l'aigle et sept animateurs un compte
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'obligation j'aime qu'ils
existent c'est dégueulasse
[Applaudissements]
bien tenté ce que tu vas t'acheter mari
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu m'avais dit qu'on n'était pas en
direct la tâche et presse m'avait dit
qu'on n'était pas des pires acteurs
stora copains
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
buzz là que cela des plus beaux fous
rires plus dedans tout puisque c'est ça
ton problème
alors on t'a laissé quelque chose mais
il m'a toits arrachés l'autre coin
takami allez-y vous tuer voilà comment
on va faire camille ça va on sait qu'ils
ont à me dire c'était commenta derrière
je vais y aller peste à poil pour y être
marche je vous entends alors oui je vous
entendez pas comment ça se passe voilà
mais j'adore oui toi t'as vu ta gueule
et tu feras tu pas ridicule tomber quoi
bien mais tout est toujours le roi dans
ce sens c'est à dire je pars pas en
vacances mais je sais que déjà quelques
personnes de l'équipe vos parts hier
autour de la table juste il ya deux
couples u2 peuvent quel beau jour de
quelqu'un la pieuvre elle viendra vous
dire bonjour tout à l'heure
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et là tu as tu devais la butte et ma vie
dit elle m'avait dit que c'était terminé
mais non mais parce qu'on a débordé mais
c'est juste moi q bah oui c'est long on
n'aurait pas les bons mecs